[Music]  sooner or later the humans are going to  find us up here you should have known  this day was coming  are we supposed to follow our king and  remain as silent as he is  we need to go to earth now we've been  hiding here too long let's go to a  rightful home if we were on earth we  would have a glorious planet to live on  drive on you're talking about betraying  your brother you're talking about  treasons  to his intentions right or wrong he's  dangerous what I'm talking about is  freedom freedom for all Inhumans  are you going to use your voice to kill  your only brother  [Music]  we will not let anyone or anything stop  us we will create our destiny nothing  can keep us from being free  [Music]